منوره جديده ام مواجهه للتهديد ورقه
داخليه ام اداه ضغطا خارجيا ايا كان يبدو
الرئيس التركي عاقدا العزمه هو علشان قوه
بلاده هجوما بريا من الحدود الجنوبيه نحو
شمال سوريا وتحديدا 30 كم للدقه لكن
المكاس تتجاوز الامان والامن القومي وفي
التاريخ ليس البعيد نحن فيه 2015 العمليه
الاولى التركيه حزب هو العداله والتنميه
يخسروا اغلبيته البرلمانيه في انتخابات
السابع من يونيو بعد اشهر في نوفمبر 2015
تحديدا وعقب سلسله تفجيرات في البلاد اعيد
الانتخابات وهذه المره فاز حزب العداله
والتنميه بزياده قدرها خمسه ملايين صوت
الان
2022 تتوفر الظروف وذاتها والحاجه اكبر في
بلدنا يعيش اعمى ازمه اقتصاديه في تاريخه
الانتخابات وعلى الابواب ومصير حزب
العداله والتنميه على المحاكم وعمليه على
اكراد سوريا من شانها ان تستقطبها اصوات
القوميين مع رهان على احداث شرخ وانقساما
في صفوف المعارضه حولها سناخذ الورقه
الداخليه ونعبر بها الحدود الى الجهه
الاخرى في الشمال السوري وهنا يقف الخصم
بحسب تركيا ضربات الجويه التركيه تمطر
مقارا مقاتلين الاكراد متحفزون وربما
منكون بتعزيزتنا تترقبوا منذ اشهر العمليه
التركيه والرهان هنا معلقا على الحمايه
الامريكيه كما كان الحال في العمليات
التركيه السابقه
خابت التوقعات هذه المره واشنطن تتفهم
المخاوف التركيه بحسب مسؤليها وقصد قوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه تمنى رساله امريكيه
اقوال لمنع الاشتياح لكن في الاحجيه قطعه
اخرى روسيا في المشهد ونشطه ايضا سواء في
الوساطه ام لاستثمار مصلحه فهي فاعله بقدر
واشنطن وذلك لموقعها على خريطه نفوذها
الراسخه في سوريا وبين التوازنات
والتفاهمات التركيه الامريكيه من جهه
والتركيه الروسيه من جهه اخرى تلعب انقره
على الموازنه بين تنسيقها مع الفاعلين
وبين اتخاذها القرار فماذا تقول
بسم الله
[موسيقى]